[Music]
okay everybody i'm really really excited
today because i have the
honor of being joined by hannah keppel
aka
moon from cobra kai hannah how you doing
today
i'm great thank you so much for having
me oh no i'm so excited you're on the
show i'm a huge fan
and in my research for this interview
you know
it felt like every day if i was like
checking on things to look up about you
your instagram is just blowing up you
have 611
followers today but it what i mean by
that is like there's literally like 20
new thousand followers a day like can
you kind of just
like go into the mindset that is like is
that surreal is it scary
oh my gosh yeah it's um definitely not
something i expected
um i think with the show blowing up like
it has i
um i'm very fortunate to to be a part of
the show and
i'm very fortunate to be noticed on the
show and
it's crazy it's definitely surreal it
also is
scary to have this many eyes on me and
paying attention to what i'm doing but i
i'm very thankful for it and i'm
thankful for the support
yeah no and it's it's really cool and
it's super exciting and it's like
showing you how much this hardcore fan
base
loves your character of moon and i
wonder
being that you're only 20 is that like a
pressure to that being this famous is
there like a pro
and con i mean i don't even consider
myself famous like i
just i'm very fortunate to be on this
crazy show and and a few people know me
like i i mean i guess face masks kind of
make a difference but i've only been
recognized like
one time at the bank and i was like okay
it's crazy
but no yeah it's it's um
it's pretty amazing i i guess because of
covet and it being weird times i don't
feel pressure in certain ways especially
like out in public
um but social media there's there's been
a lot more pressure in kind of that
regards for better or worse i'd say
so speaking of your other you know
mysteries of social media for hannah
keppel there is this
mysterious thing i have to ask about
where if i hit your twitter
someone has the uh handle hannah kepler
and it says reserved
for hannah keppel will you be taking
that username
yeah someone's saving it for you they
have a picture of you it just says
reserved for hannah capple official user
wow okay so yeah i used to have a
twitter
um and then i honestly social media very
much overwhelms me and gives me anxiety
so i'm like i'm gonna knock it down to
just instagram
i i enjoy instagram the most and i feel
like
i don't know i i enjoy instagram the
most so that's the one i have but that's
so funny i mean
hey that's really nice of them i know
that somebody has a tick tock with
hannah keppel that's not me
for anybody okay out there i only have
instagram
um but yeah that's that's funny okay
yeah there's just people waiting for you
to cross platform here
but uh it's interesting you had
mentioned you know about
corona times and wearing face masks and
um
you know season four currently in
production of cobra kai
so has it been a like really different
experience to when you were filming
season three like has it been weird how
they like kind of set it up
yeah so i'm not allowed to talk about
season four or if i'm involved or not
but i did just film a project a
different project
um okay in atlanta as well and it's been
during covet times
and um honestly i was kind of scared
about it and like not being able to
connect with people
as much but but filming during covet
hasn't been too bad everybody's very
safe people on set and so i'm sure
they're doing the same thing with four
we'll see we'll see i like that so
you're
that's a smart answer you're just
tiptoeing around season four but
um when uh you know it's interesting too
because
when i see you play moon you absolutely
like steal the screen when your
character comes on screen
but to get a role like that in a
huge franchise what was the audition
process like to
get that role like how'd that come about
yeah sure so
i um i've grown up in a smaller town i
got into the film industry art was
interested in the film industry in high
school and um
i like signed up to the one agency that
we had in my town
and i just started sending self tapes
and so cobra kai was just another self
tape i got
it was like ralph macchio youtube red
and i was like wait who's ralph macchio
and youtube does tv shows like what
i was like oh my god the karate kid of
course um
and so i sent in a self tape and i got
some really great feedback and they
wanted me to come to atlanta
and audition in front of everybody and
so
i drove down and i did the the audition
in person
and then it was very quick like a couple
days later they wanted me to come back
to atlanta for the table read and they
told me i got it
so it was a whirlwind yeah it was
amazing
yeah i mean that's that's really cool
and it's exciting to see like
a show like this just blow up so fast
and just develop
like a fan base that's like almost like
the marvel fan base where they're
excited to see characters return
they're so passionate about everyone's
debating theories oh my gosh um
yeah so so when you're not on set though
during these times
what do you like to do to like pass the
time do you watch a lot of tv do you
watch a lot of movies
you read what's like hannah do on a
daily day okay
so i do love to read um i haven't done a
lot of it super recently i've been kind
of busy but i do love to read
i did this a couple months ago and i'm
starting for february where i want to
watch a film
every day in the month of february
because i
i just i love movies it's a little
harder for me to watch
tv shows i have to admit to for whatever
reason
i have such a hard time finishing series
so i'm starting with movies i'll get
better with tv shows
um but i'm really fortunate that i'm i'm
with my family right now so i love to
spend time with them
we've got some beautiful trails so i
love to be outside hiking and stuff so
i try and be active and and do stuff
keep myself busy
i love your dog made the interview too
that is a cute dog
i just noticed i literally just thought
i was like hi yeah that's my dog roxy
that's awesome um yeah and that that
makes total sense you know
i i think what's cool too about like you
know
watching a film a day you just learn so
much from that and
you know reddit has all these great
lists like there's top 150 mind-blowing
films you can just knock those out
you know and and when you're talking
about tv my best advice
is to watch at 1.2 speed on netflix and
you'll be
going through bingen's shows that would
be rather overwhelming
but um i'll try and i didn't do that
with cobra kai i left cobra guy at one
speed
but uh so i really also
love this video you did on instagram i
think it was last year or the year
before but
where you're actually singing uh dream a
little dream of me
and it hit me because you know i love
the undoing of nicole kidman and it
reminded me of her cover she did of the
song
you did it first and you nailed it and i
wonder
do you really like want to do singing
more like
serious career that like do you make
music do you play guitar like we see
moon does it's that whole field yeah so
i
my my background is primarily musical
theater that's how i kind of got my foot
in the door
um it's my first love i i grew up doing
it loved it um
in regards to singing by itself i get
terrible stage fright
um like just singing as hannah i love to
sing his characters
um so i don't think i'll ever
be in the industry as like an
entertainer but i would absolutely love
to do a movie musical
um that's a huge goal of mine i think
that would be super fun to be a part of
um i'm dabbling in like writing music i
don't know if it's necessarily for
me or other people um but i'd love to
learn how to play instruments as well i
think music
is just more more for me personally and
then maybe someday i'll share
more with the public i love it that's
exciting and
yeah it's interesting too because you
know i
feel like you're someone that when
someone's starting at a young age and
getting so successful acting it makes
you wonder too like
who was your idol growing up when you
were younger like what really drew you
to acting was like a specific actress or
actor that was like oh my god i want to
do this
i'm trying to think i think what
was the huge kind of pivotal turn for me
was actually when i was in eighth grade
and i
did um the wizard of oz at our state
theater i was dorothy
and all right i did a lot of research
for that and i kind of
i mean judy has such a
sad sad story but i i did kind of you
know
look up to her in that sense and i i
loved her work
and movie musicals um and then i also
had just a really great mentor for that
show who was a director his name is dave
hart
he uh recently passed away but he really
was a huge inspiration for me to just
kind of believe in myself
and and follow my passions and um
i know he's not a super famous person
but he he meant a lot to me and he got
me
got me started no that's that's really
cool to hear and that's
inspirational to everyone too and um
yeah i think there's that
part of the fan base that just wants to
know more about hannah you know and
that's
what's cool when you're on a hit show
like this like fan bases just get so
excited about the actors and actors on
it i think that's really exciting for
you because you'll be now
always in the cobra kai like rome
universe to be at comic cons and
signatures when we go back to that
obviously yeah exactly
okay so the elephant in the room i have
to ask is in your insta
instabio it says hi florence peer has
she said hi back
no not yet god damn it
i know probably someday i
i'm obsessed with her i think she's an
incredible actor she seems like such a
wonderful human being
and i love all of her work so we'll see
fingers crossed
fingers crossed uh everyone please check
out hannah keppel on cobra kai if you
haven't watched the show at all you can
watch all three seasons on netflix
now and please follow her on instagram
at hannah keppel
and is there anything else you want to
plug before i let you go um i mean
honestly thank you so much for having me
uh watch out for season four that's
that's happening
and i do have a show coming out called
tell me your secrets on amazon prime
february's 19th i'm super excited about
i just filmed something that i can't
quite talk about yet but i'm hoping
that'll come out
around halloween um so yeah just be on
the lookout and thank you so much steve
thank you hannah for joining me and i
hope to talk to you in the future yes
for sure